thank you
all right and if anyone can stand up
with your numbers or hold your numbers
high and just a friendly reminder to
name your outlet and Country because
you're raising your um
you're raising your number
okay we are going to start in the
virtual Press Room with Canal 2
International and then next up we will
go to number 338 after canal 2.
[Music]
central Africa so my question was that
first of all in French
uh
Almighty
yes
there we go all right and we have number
338 up next before we have um we're
going back to the virtual Press Room so
338 yes hello congratulations so winning
your Oscar incredible work my name is
Nicolette Morales and I'm with culture
Focus Magazine and I think that and as
we all know the the progress and the
work that you've done on Brandon Frazier
was just incredible but I want to know
what are some of the techniques and
challenges that you faced along the the
way we don't see the hard work we see
the final product but I'm sure there's a
lot of hours and hard sweaty bloody
tears ago behind the work
um and if you can Enlighten us a little
bit of behind the scenes so making that
come to life thank you
thank you
well the the makeup on Brendan was a was
especially complicated due to the fact
that we we were in covet times and we
didn't have access to him
and because of that we we had to really
break new grounds in terms of of how
makeups were not only designed but uh
fabricated in the in the shop and then
applied on set so where normally what we
do is that we we have the actor coming
into the studio and we do a live cast of
his body and his head
we couldn't do that uh we were in the
early days of the pandemic we didn't
know like necessarily what was the
proper protocol that time and we've been
um doing a bunch of In-House tests in
the past like few years with creating
Prosthetics
through digital uh workflow
and while nobody else had done that
before like we were actually managing to
get some really good results and when
Darren called to do his movie and we
didn't have access to the to Brandon I
was like maybe this is the time to do it
so
again like unlike anything else none of
the the other nominations tonight
everything was created sculpted in the
computer 3D printed we've done molds
from those sculptures and then we were
able to apply that on him without ever
meeting Brendan in person so that was
that was something
all right and for our last
mea worldwide
hello hello everyone uh congratulations
for the win and my name is
worldwide India uh you just said that
you you know you taste a lot of
challenges while applying the makeup or
you know everything else so how was
Brendan Fraser reacting to it and did
you feel any pressure when you know the
movie was in all of this controversy
around the weight and obesity
I've missed the last part
I guess it was um was this about how how
he handled the makeup
yes yes yes ma'am yes oh he was a champ
and we uh the makeup took about four
hours right yeah it took seven hours at
first and then two and a half hours yeah
it got narrowed down but um you know
Adrian created like a cooling suit for
him thank goodness that that kept him
cool under the Prosthetics and um he's
so patient and and
willing to do anything for the role and
to create that look
wonderful thank you so much and
congratulations one more time
[Applause]